-- valuable experience.
OK, today we're going to start
talking about a particular class
of algorithms called greedy
algorithms.
But we're going to do it in the
context of graphs.
So, I want to review a little
bit about graphs,
which mostly you can find in
the textbook in appendix B.
And so, if you haven't reviewed
in appendix B recently,
please sit down and review
appendix B.
It will pay off especially
during our take-home quiz.
So, just reminder,
a digraph, what's a digraph?
What's that short for?
Directed graph,
OK?
G equals (V,E),
OK, has a set,
V, of vertices.
And, I always get people
telling me that I have one
vertice.
The singular is not vertice;
it is vertex,
OK?
The plural is vertices.
The singular is vertex.
It's one of those weird English
words.
It's probably originally like
French or something,
right?
I don't know.
OK, anyway, and we have a set,
E, which is a subset of V cross
V of edges.
So that's a digraph.
And undirected graph,
E contains unordered pairs.
OK, and, sorry?
It's Latin, OK,
so it's probably pretty old,
then, in English.
I guess the vertex would be a
little bit of a giveaway that
maybe it wasn't French.
It started to be used in 1570,
OK.
OK, good, OK,
so the number of edges is,
whether it's directed or
undirected, is O of what?
V^2, good.
OK, and one of the conventions
that will have when we're
dealing, once we get into
graphs, we deal a lot with sets.
We generally drop the vertical
bar notation within O's just
because it's applied.
It just makes it messier.
So, once again,
another abuse of notation.
It really should be order the
size of V^2, but it just messes
up, I mean, it's just more stuff
to write down.
And, you're multiplying these
things, and all those vertical
bars.
Since they don't even have a
sense to the vertical bar,
it gets messy.
So, we just drop the vertical
bars there when it's in
asymptotic notation.
So, E is order V^2 when it's a
set of pairs,
because if it's a set of pairs,
it's at most n choose two,
which is where it's at most n^2
over 2, here it could be,
at most, sorry,
V^2 over 2, here it's at most
V^2.
And then, another property that
sometimes comes up is if the G
is connected,
we have another bound,
implies that the size of E is
at least the size of V minus
one.
OK, so if it's connected,
meaning, what does it mean to
have a graph that's connected?
Yeah, there's a path from any
vertex to any other vertex in
the graph.
That's what it means to be
connected.
So if that's the case,
that a number of edges is at
least the number of vertices
minus one, OK?
And so, what that says,
so one of the things we'll get
into, a fact that I just wanted
to remind you,
is that in that case,
if I look at log E,
OK, log of the number of edges,
that is O of log V.
And by this,
is omega of log V.
So, it's equal to theta of log
V.
OK, so basically the number of,
in the case of a connected
graph, the number of edges,
and the number of vertices are
polynomially related.
So, their logs are comparable.
OK, so that's helpful just to
know because sometimes I just
get questions later on where
people will say,
oh, you showed it was log E but
you didn't show it was log V.
And I could point out that it's
the same thing.
OK, so there's various ways of
representing graphs in
computers, and I'm just going to
cover a couple of the important
ones.
There's actually more.
We'll see some more.
So, the simplest one is what's
called an adjacency matrix.
An adjacency matrix of the
graph, G, equals (V,E),
where, for simplicity,
I'll let V be the set of
integers from one up to n,
OK, is the n by n matrix A
given by the ij-th at the entry
is simply one if the edge,
ij, is in the edge set and zero
if ij is not in the edge set.
OK, so it's simply the matrix
where you say,
the ij entry is one if it's in
the matrix.
So, this is,
in some sense,
giving you the predicate for,
is there an edge from i to j?
OK, remember,
predicate is Boolean formula
that is either zero or one,
and in this case,
you're saying it's one if there
is an edge from i to j and zero
otherwise.
OK, sometimes you have edge
weighted graphs,
and then sometimes what people
will do is replace this by edge
weights.
OK, it will be the weight of
the edge from i to j.
So, let's just do an example of
that just to make sure that our
intuition corresponds to our
mathematical definitions.
So, here's an example graph.
Let's say that's our graph.
So let's just draw the
adjacency the matrix.
OK, so what this says:
is there's an edge from one to
one?
And the answer is no.
Is there an edge from one to
two?
Yes.
Is there an edge from one to
three here?
Yep.
Is there an edge for one to
four?
No.
Is there an edge from two until
one?
No.
Two to two?
Two to three?
Yes.
Two to four?
No.
No edges going out of three.
Edge from four to three,
and that's it.
That's the adjacency matrix for
this particular graph,
OK?
And so, I can represent a graph
as this adjacency matrix.
OK, when I represent it in this
way, how much storage do I need?
OK, n^2 or V^2 because the size
is the same thing for V^2
storage, OK, and that's what we
call a dense representation.
OK, it works well when the
graph is dense.
So, the graph is dense if the
number of edges is close to all
of the edges possible.
OK, then this is a good
representation.
But for many types of graphs,
the number of edges is much
less than the possible number of
edges, in which case we say the
graph is sparse.
Can somebody give me an example
of a sparse graph?
A class of graphs:
so, I want a class of graphs
that as n grows,
the number of edges in the
graph doesn't grow as the
square, but grows rather as
something much smaller.
A linked list,
so, a chain,
OK, if you look at it from a
graph theoretically,
is a perfectly good example:
only n edges in the chain for a
chain of length n.
So therefore,
the number of edges would be
order V.
And in particular,
you'd only have one edge per
row here.
What other graphs are sparse?
Yeah?
Good, a planar graph,
a graph that can be drawn in a
plane turns out that if it has V
vertices has,
and V is at least three,
then it has,
at most, three V minus six
edges.
So, it turns out that's order V
edges again.
What's another example of a
common graph?
Yeah, binary tree,
or even actually any tree,
you know, what's called a free
tree if you read the appendix,
OK, a tree that just is a
connected graph that has no
cycles, OK, is another example.
What's an example of a graph
that's dense?
A complete graph,
OK: it's all ones,
OK, or if you have edge
weights, it would be a
completely filled in matrix.
OK, good.
So, this is good for dense
representation.
But sometimes you want to have
a sparse representation so we
don't have to spend V^2 space to
deal with all of the,
where most of it's going to be
zeroes.
OK, it's sort of like,
if we know why it's zero,
why bother representing it as
zero?
So, one such representation is
an adjacency list
representation.
Actually, adjacency list of a
given vertex is the list,
which we denote by Adj of V,
of vertices adjacent to V.
OK, just in terms by their
terminology, vertices are
adjacent, but edges are incident
on vertices.
OK, so the incidence is a
relation between a vertex and an
edge.
An adjacency is a relation
between two vertices.
OK, that's just the language.
Why they use to different
terms, I don't know,
but that's what they do.
So, in the graph,
for example,
the adjacency list for vertex
one is just the list or the set
of two three because one has
going out of one are edges to
two and three.
The adjacency list for two is
just three, four,
three.
It's the empty set,
and for four,
it is three.
OK, so that's the
representation.
Now, if we want to figure out
how much storage is required for
this representation,
OK, we need to understand how
long the adjacency list is.
So, what is the length of an
adjacency list of a vertex,
V?
What name do we give to that?
It's the degree.
So, in an undirected graph,
we call it the degree of the
vertex.
This is undirected.
OK, about here,
OK.
So that's an undirected case.
In the directed case,
OK, actually I guess the way we
should do this is say this.
If the degree,
we call it the out degree for a
digraph.
OK, so in a digraph,
we have an out degree and an in
degree for each vertex.
So here, the in degree is
three.
Here, the out degree is two,
OK?
So, one of the important lemma
that comes up is what's called
the handshaking lemma.
OK, it's one of these
mathematical lemmas.
And so, it comes from a story.
Go to a dinner party,
and everybody at the dinner
party shakes other people's
hands.
Some people may not shake
anybody's hand.
Some people may shake several
people's hands.
Nobody shakes hands with
themselves.
And at some point during the
dinner party,
the host goes around and counts
up how many, the sum,
of the number of hands that
each person has shaken.
OK, so he says,
how many did you shake?
How many did you shake?
He adds them up,
OK, and that number is
guaranteed to be even.
OK, that's the handshaking
lemma.
Or, stated a little bit more
precisely, if I take for any
graph the degree of the vertex,
and sum them all up,
that's how many hands everybody
shook, OK, that's actually equal
to always twice the number of
edges.
So, why is that going to be
true?
Why is that going to be twice
the number of edges?
Yeah?
Yeah.
Every time you put in an edge,
you add one to the degree of
each person on each end.
So, it's just two different
ways of counting up the same
number of edges.
OK, I can go around,
and if you imagine that,
that every time I count the
degree of the node,
I put a mark on every edge.
Then, when I'm done,
every edge has two marks on it,
one for each end.
OK: a pretty simple theorem.
So, what that says is that for
undirected graphs,
that implies that the adjacency
list representation,
uses how much storage?
OK, at most,
2E, so order E because that's
not all.
Yeah, so you have to have the
number of vertices plus order
the number of edges,
OK, whether it's directed or
undirected because I may have a
graph, say it has a whole bunch
of vertices and no edges,
that's still going to cost me
order V, OK?
So, it uses theta of V plus E
storage.
And, it's basically the same
thing asymptotically.
In fact, it's easier to see in
some sense for digraphs because
for digraphs,
what I do is I just add up the
out degrees, and that equal to
E, OK, if I add up the out
degrees as equally.
In fact, this is kind of like
it amortized analysis,
if you will,
a book keeping analysis,
that if I'm adding up the total
number of edges,
one way of doing it is
accounting for a vertex by
vertex.
OK, so for each vertex,
I basically can take each
degree, and basically each
vertex, look at the degree,
and that allocating of account
per edge, and then ending up
with twice the number of edges,
that's exactly accounting type
of analysis that we might do for
amortized analysis.
OK, so we'll see that.
So, this is a sparse
representation,
and it's often better than an
adjacency matrix.
For example,
you can imagine if the World
Wide Web were done with an
adjacency matrix as opposed to,
essentially,
with an adjacency list type of
representation.
Every link on the World Wide
Web, I had to say,
here are the ones that I'm
connected to,
and here are all the ones I'm
not connected to.
OK, that list of things you're
not connected to for a given
page would be pretty
dramatically,
show you that there is an
advantage to sparse
representation.
On the other hand,
one of the nice things about an
adjacency matrix representation
is that each edge can be
represented with a single bit,
whereas typical when I'm
representing things with an
adjacency list representation,
how many bits am I going to
need to represent each
adjacency?
You'll need order log of V to
be able to name each different
vertex.
OK, the log of the number is
the number of bits that I need.
So, there are places where this
is actually a far more efficient
representation.
In particular,
if you have a very dense graph,
OK, this may be a better way of
representing it.
OK, the other thing I want you
to get, and we're going to see
more of this in particular next
week, is that a matrix and a
graph, there are two ways of
looking at the same thing.
OK, and in fact,
there's a lot of graph theory
that when you do things like
multiply the adjacency matrix,
OK, and so forth.
So, there's a lot of
commonality between graphs and
matrices, a lot of mathematics
that if it applies for one,
it applies to the other.
Do you have a question,
or just holding your finger in
the air?
OK, good.
OK, so that's all just review.
Now I want to get onto today's
lecture.
OK, so any questions about
graphs?
So, this is a good time to
review appendix B.
there are a lot of great
properties in there,
and in particular,
there is a theorem that we're
going to cover today that we're
going to talk about today,
which is properties of trees.
Trees are very special kinds of
graphs, so I really want you to
go and look to see what the
properties are.
There is, I think,
something like six different
definitions of trees that are
all equivalent,
OK, and so, I think a very good
idea to go through and read
through that theorem.
We're not going to prove it in
class, but really,
provides a very good basis for
the thinking that we're going to
be doing today.
And we'll see more of that in
the future.
OK, so today,
we're going to talk about
minimum spanning trees.
OK, this is one of the world's
most important algorithms.
OK, it is important in
distributed systems.
It's one of the first things
that almost any distributed
system tries to find is a
minimum spanning tree of the
nodes that happened to be alive
at any point,
OK?
And one of the people who
developed an algorithm for this,
we'll talk about this a little
bit later, OK,
it was the basis of the billing
system for AT&T for many years
while it was a monopoly.
OK, so very important kind of
thing.
It's got a huge number of
applications.
So the problem is the
following.
You have a connected undirected
graph,
G equals (V,E),
with an edge weight function,
w, which maps the edges into
weights that are real numbers.
And for today's lecture,
we're going to make an
important assumption,
OK, for simplicity.
The book does not make this
assumption.
And so, I encourage you to look
at the alternative presentation
or, because what they do in the
book is much more general,
but for simplicity and
intuition, I'm going to make
this a little bit easier.
We're going to assume that all
edge weights are distinct.
OK, all edge weights are
distinct.
So what does that mean?
What does that mean that this
function, w, what property does
the function,
w, have if all edge weights are
distinct?
Who remembers their discreet
math?
It's injective.
OK, it's one to one.
OK, it's not one to one and
onto necessarily.
In fact, it would be kind of
hard to do that because that's a
pretty big set.
OK, but it's one to one.
It's injective.
OK, so that's what we're going
to assume for simplicity.
OK, and the book,
they don't assume that.
It just means that the way you
have to state things is just a
little more precise.
It has to be more technically
precise.
So, that's the input.
The output is--
The output is a spanning tree,
T, and by spanning tree,
we mean it connects all the
vertices.
OK, and it's got to have
minimum weight.
OK, so we can write the weight
of the tree is going to be,
by that, we meet the sum over
all edges that are in the tree
of the weight of the individual
edges.
OK, so here I'(V,E) done a
little bit of abusive notation,
which is that what I should be
writing is w of the edge (u,v)
because this is a mapping from
edges, which would give me a
double parentheses.
And, you know,
as you know,
I love to abuse notation.
So, I'm going to drop that
extra parentheses,
because we understand that it's
really the weight of the edge,
OK, not the weight of the
ordered pair.
So, that's just a little
notational convenience.
OK, so one of the things,
when we do the take-home exam,
notational convenience can make
the difference between having a
horrible time writing up a
problem, and an easy time.
So, it's worth thinking about
what kinds of notation you'll
use in writing up solutions to
problems, and so forth.
OK, and just in general,
a technical communication,
you adopt good notation people
understand you.
You adopt a poor notation:
nobody pays attention to what
you're doing because they don't
understand what you're saying.
OK, so let's do an example.
OK, so here's a graph.
I think for this,
somebody asked once if I was
inspired by biochemistry or
something, OK,
but I wasn't.
I was just writing these things
down, OK?
So, here's a graph.
And let's give us some edge
weights.
OK, so there are some edge
And now, what we want is we
want to find a tree.
So a connected acyclic graph
such that every vertex is part
of the tree.
But it's got to have the
minimum weight possible.
OK, so can somebody suggest to
me some edges that have to be in
this minimum spanning tree?
Yeah, so nine,
good.
Nine has to be in there
because, why?
It's the only one connecting it
to this vertex,
OK?
And likewise,
15 has to be in there.
So those both have to be in.
What other edges have to be in?
Which one?
14 has to be it.
Why does 14 have to be in?
Well, one of 14 and three has
to be in there.
I want the minimum weight.
The one that has the overall
smallest weight.
So, can somebody argue to me
that three has to be in there?
Yeah?
That's the minimum of two,
which means that if I had a,
if you add something you said
was a minimum spanning tree that
didn't include three,
right, and so therefore it had
to include 14,
then I could just delete this
edge, 14, and put in edge three.
And, I have something of lower
weight, right?
So, three has to be in there.
What other edges have to be in
there?
Do a little puzzle logic.
Six and five have to be in
there.
Why do they have to be in
there?
Yeah, well, I mean,
it could be connected through
this or something.
It doesn't necessarily have to
go this way.
Six definitely has to be in
there for the same reason that
three had to be,
right?
Because we got two choices to
connect up this guy.
And so, if everything were
connected but it weren't,
12, I mean, and 12 was in
there.
I could always,
then, say, well,
let's connect them up this way
instead.
OK, so definitely that's in
there.
I still don't have everything
connected up.
What else has to be in there
for minimum spanning tree?
Seven, five,
and eight, why seven,
five, and eight?
OK, so can we argue those one
at a time?
Why does five have to be in
there?
Yeah?
OK, so we have four connected
components because we have this
one, this one,
we actually have,
yeah, this one here,
and this one,
good.
We need at least three edges to
connect them because each edge
is going to reduce the connected
components by one.
OK, so we need three edges,
and those are the three
cheapest ones.
And they work.
That works, right?
Any other edges are going to be
bigger, so that works.
Good.
OK, and so, now do we have a
spanning tree?
Everything is,
we have one big connected graph
here, right?
Is that what I got?
Hey, that's the same as what I
got.
Life is predictable.
OK, so, so everybody had the
idea of what a minimum spanning
tree is, then,
out of this,
OK, what's going on there?
So, let's first of all make
some observations about this
puzzle.
And what I want to do is remind
you about the optimal
substructure property because it
turns out minimum spanning tree
has a great optimal substructure
property.
OK, so the setup is going to
be, we're going to have some
minimum spanning tree.
Let's call it T.
And, I'm going to show that
with the other edges in the
graph, are not going to be
shown.
OK, so here's a graph.
It looks like the one I have my
piece of paper here.
OK, so the idea is,
this is some minimum spanning
tree.
Now, we want to look at a
property of optimal
substructure.
And the way I'm going to get
that, is, I'm going to remove
some edge, (u,v),
move an arbitrary edge,
(u,v), in the minimum spanning
tree.
So, let's call this u and this
V.
And so, we're removing this
edge.
OK, so when I remove an edge in
a tree, what happens to the
tree?
What's left?
I have two trees left,
OK?
I have two trees left.
Now, proving that,
that's basically one of the
properties in that appendix,
and the properties of trees
that I want you to read,
OK, because you can actually
prove that kind of thing rather
than it just being obvious,
which is, OK?
OK, so we remove that.
Then, T is partitioned into two
subtrees.
And, we'll call them T_1 and
T_2.
So, here's one subtree,
and here's another subtree.
We'(V,E) partitioned it.
No matter what edge I picked,
there would be two subtrees
that it's partitioned into.
Even if the sub tree is a
trivial subtree,
for example,
it just has a single node in it
and no edges.
So, the theorem that we'll
prove demonstrates a property of
optimal substructure.
T_1 is a minimum spanning tree
for the graph,
G_1, E_1,
a subgraph of G induced by the
vertices in T_1.
OK, that is,
V_1 is just the vertices in T_1
is what it means to be induced.
OK, so V_1 is the vertices in
T_1.
So, in this picture,
I didn't label it.
This is T_1.
This is T_2.
In this picture,
these are the vertices of T_1.
So, that's V_1,
OK?
And, E_1 is the set of pairs of
vertices, x and y,
that are the edges that are in
E_1 such that both x and y
belong to V_1.
OK, so I haven't shown the
edges of G here.
But basically,
if an edge went from here to
here, that would be in the E_1.
If it went from here to here,
it would not.
And if it went from here to
here, it would not.
OK, so the vertices,
the subgraph induced by the
vertices of T_1 are just those
that connect up things in T_1,
and similarly for T_2.
So, the theorem says that if I
look at just the edges within
the graph here,
G_1, those that are induced by
these vertices,
T_1 is, in fact,
a minimum spanning tree for
that subgraph.
That's what the theorem says.
OK, if I look over here
conversely, or correspondingly,
if I look at the set of edges
that are induced by this set of
vertices, the vertices in T_2,
in fact, T_2 is a minimum
spanning tree on that subgraph.
OK, OK, we can even do it over
here.
If I took a look,
for example,
at these, let's see,
let's say we cut out five,
and if I cut out edge five,
that T_1 would be these four
vertices here.
And, the point is that if I
look at the subgraph induced on
that, that these edges here.
In fact, the six,
eight, and three are all edges
in a minimum spanning tree for
that subgraph.
OK, so that's what the theorem
says.
So let's prove it.
OK, and so what technique are
we going to use to prove it?
OK, we learned this technique
last time: hint,
hint.
It's something you do it in
your text editor all the time:
cut and paste,
good, cut and paste.
OK, so the weight of T I can
express as the weight of the
edge I removed,
plus the weight of T_1,
plus the weight of T_2.
OK, so that's the total weight.
So, the argument is pretty
simple.
Suppose that there were some
T_1 prime that was better than
T_1 for G_1.
Suppose I had some better way
of forming a spanning tree.
OK, then I would make up a T
prime, which just contained the
edges, (u,v),
and T_1 prime,
union T_2.
So, I would take,
if I had a better spanning
tree, a spanning tree of lower
weight for T_1.
And I call that T_1 prime.
I just substitute that and make
up a spanning tree that
consisted of my edge,
(u,v), whatever works well for
T_1 prime and whatever works
well for T.
And, that would be a spanning
tree.
And it would be better than T
itself was for G,
OK, because the weight of these
is just as the weight for this,
I now just get to use the
weight of T_1 prime,
and that's less.
And so, therefore,
the assumption that T was a
minimum spanning tree would be
violated if I could find a
better one for the subpiece.
So, we have this nice property
of optimal substructure.
OK, I have subproblems that
exhibit optimal,
if I have a globally optimal
solution to the whole problem
within it, I can find optimal
solutions to subproblems.
So, now the question is,
that's one hallmark.
That's one hallmark of dynamic
programming.
What about overlapping
subproblems?
Do I have that property?
Do I have overlapping
subproblems over here for this
type of problem?
So, imagine,
for example,
that I'm removing different
edges.
I look at the space of taking a
given edge, and removing it.
It partitions it into two
pieces, and now I have another
piece.
And I remove it,
etc.
Am I going to end up getting a
bunch of subproblems that are
similar in there?
Yeah, I am.
OK, if I take out this one,
then I take out,
say, this one here,
and then I'll have another tree
here and here.
OK, that would be the same as
if I had originally taken this
out, and then taken that one
out.
If I look at simple ordering of
taking out the edges,
I'm going to end up with a
whole bunch of overlapping
subproblems.
Yeah, OK.
So then, what does that suggest
we use as an approach?
Dynamic programming,
good.
What a surprise!
Yes, OK, you could use dynamic
programming.
But it turns out that minimum
spanning tree exhibits an even
more powerful property.
OK, so we'(V,E) got all the
clues for dynamic programming,
but it turns out that there's
an even bigger clue that's going
to help us to use an even more
powerful technique.
And that, we call,
the hallmark for greedy
algorithms.
And that is,
we have a thing called the
greedy choice property,
which says that a locally
optimal choice is globally
optimal.
And, of course,
as all these hallmarks is the
kind of thing you want to box,
OK, because these are the clues
that you're going to be able to
do that.
So, we have this property that
we call the greedy choice
property.
I'm going to show you how it
works in this case.
And when you have a greedy
choice property,
it turns out you can do even
better that dynamic programming.
OK, so when you see the two
dynamic programming properties,
there is a clue that says
dynamic programming,
yes, but also it says,
let me see whether it also has
this greedy property because if
it does, you're going to come up
with something that's even
better than dynamic programming,
OK?
So, if you just have the two,
you can usually do dynamic
programming, but if you have
this third one,
it's like, whoa!
Jackpot!
OK, so here's the theorem we'll
prove to illustrate this idea.
Once again, these are not,
all these hallmarks are not
things.
They are heuristics.
I can't give you an algorithm
to say, here's where dynamic
programming works,
or here's where greedy
algorithms work.
But I can sort of indicate when
they work, the kind of structure
they have.
OK, so here's the theorem.
So let's let T be the MST of
our graph.
And, let's let A be any subset
of V, so, some subset of
vertices.
And now, let's suppose that
edge, (u,v), is the least weight
edge connecting our set A to A
complement, that is,
V minus A.
Then the theorem says that
(u,v) is in the minimum spanning
tree.
So let's just take a look at
our graph over here and see if
that's, in fact,
the case.
OK, so let's take,
so one thing I could do for A
is just take a singleton node.
So, I take a singleton node,
let's say this guy here,
that can be my A,
and everything else is V minus
A.
And I look at the least weight
edge connecting this to
everything else.
Well, there are only two edges
that connect it to everything
else.
And the theorem says that the
lighter one is in the minimum
spanning tree.
Hey, I win.
OK, if you take a look,
every vertex that I pick,
the latest edge coming out of
that vertex is in the minimum
spanning tree.
OK, the lightest weight edge
coming out, but that's not all
the edges that are in here.
OK, or let's just imagine,
let's take a look at these
three vertices connected to this
set of vertices.
I have three edges is going
across.
The least weight one is five.
That's the minimum spanning
tree.
Or, I can cut it this way.
OK, the ones above one,
the edges going down are seven,
eight, and 14.
Seven is the least weight.
It's in the minimum spanning
tree.
So, no matter how I choose,
I could make this one in,
this one out,
this one in,
take a look at what all the
edges are.
Which ever one to the least
weight: it's in the minimum
spanning tree.
So, in some sense,
that's a local property because
I don't have to look at what the
rest of the tree is.
I'm just looking at some small
set of vertices if I wish,
and I say, well,
if I wanted to connect that set
of vertices to the rest of the
world, what would I pick?
I'd pick the cheapest one.
That's the greedy approach.
It turns out,
that wins, OK,
that picking that thing that's
locally good for that subset,
A, OK, is also globally good.
OK, it optimizes the overall
function.
That's what the theorem says,
OK?
So, let's prove this theorem.
Any questions about this?
OK, let's prove this theorem.
So, we have (u,v) is the least
weight edge connecting A to D
minus A.
So, let's suppose that this
edge, (u,v), is not in the
minimum spanning tree.
OK, let's suppose that somehow
there is a minimum spanning tree
that doesn't include this least
weight edge.
OK, so what technique you think
will use to prove to get a
contradiction here?
Cut and paste,
good.
Yeah, we're going to cut paste.
OK, we're going to cut and
paste.
So here, I did an example.
OK, so --
OK, and so I'm going to use the
notation.
I'm going to color some of
these in.
OK, and so my notation here is
this is an element of A,
and color it in.
It's an element of V minus A.
OK, so if it's not colored it,
that's an A.
This is my minimum spanning
tree.
Once again, I'm not showing the
overall edges of all the graphs,
but they're there,
OK?
So, my edge,
(u,v), which is not my minimum
spanning tree I say,
let's say is this edge here.
It's an edge from u,
u as in A, v as in V minus A.
OK, so everybody see the setup?
So, I want to prove that this
edge should have been in the
minimum spanning tree,
OK, that the contention that
this is a minimum spanning tree,
and does include (u,v) is
wrong.
So, what I want to do,
that, is I have a tree here,
T, and I have two vertices,
u and v, and in a tree,
between any two vertices there
is a unique, simple path:
simple path meaning it doesn't
go back and forth and repeat
edges or vertices.
OK, there's a unique,
simple path from u to v.
So, let's consider that path.
OK, and the way that I know
that that path exists is because
I'(V,E) read appendix B of the
textbook, section B.5.1,
OK, which has this nice theorem
about properties of trees.
OK, so that's how I know that
there exists a unique,
simple path.
OK, so now we're going to do is
take a look at that path.
So in this case,
it goes from here,
to here, to here,
to here.
And along that path,
there must be a point where I
connect from a vertex in A to a
vertex in V minus A.
Why?
Well, because this is in A.
This is in V minus A.
So, along the path somewhere,
there must be a transition.
OK, they are not all in A,
OK, because in particular,
V isn't.
OK, so we're going to do is
swap (u,v) with the first edge
on this path that connects a
vertex in A to a vertex in V
minus A.
So in this case,
it's this edge here.
I go from A to V minus A.
In general, I might be
alternating many times,
OK, and I just picked the first
one that I encounter.
OK, that this guy here.
And what I do is I put this
edge in.
OK, so then,
what happens?
Well, the edge,
(u,v), is the lightest thing
connecting something in A to
something in V minus A.
So that means,
in particular,
it's lighter than this edge,
has lower weight.
So, by swapping this,
I'(V,E) created a tree with
lower overall weight,
contradicting the assumption
that this other thing was a
minimum spanning tree.
OK: so, a lower weight spanning
tree than T results,
and that's a contradiction --
-- than T results.
And that's a contradiction,
OK?
How are we doing?
Everybody with me?
OK, now we get to do some
algorithms.
Yea!
So, we are going to do an
algorithm called Prim's
algorithm.
Prim eventually became a very
high-up at AT&T because he
invented this algorithm for
minimum spanning trees,
and it was used in all of the
billing code for AT&T for many
years.
He was very high up at Bell
Labs back in the heyday of Bell
Laboratories.
OK, so it just shows,
all you have to do is invent an
algorithm.
You too can be a president of a
corporate monopoly.
Of course, the government can
do things to monopolies,
but anyway, if that's your
mission in life,
invent an algorithm.
OK, so here's the idea.
What we're going to do is we're
going to maintain V minus A as a
priority queue.
We'll call it Q.
And each vertex,
we're going to key each vertex
in Q with the weight of the
least weight edge,
connecting it to a vertex in A.
So here's the code.
So, we're going to start out
with Q being all vertices.
So, we start out with A being,
if you will,
the empty set.
OK, and what we're going to do
it is the least weight edge,
therefore, for everything in
the priority queue is basically
going to be infinity because
none of them have any edges.
The least weight edge to the
empty set is going to be empty.
And then, we're going to start
out with one guy.
We'll call him S,
which will set to zero for some
arbitrary S in V.
And then, the main part of the
algorithm kicks in.
So that's our initialization.
OK, when we do the analysis,
I'm going to write some stuff
on the left hand side of the
board.
So if you're taking notes,
you may want to also leave a
little bit of space on the left
hand side of your notes.
So, while Q is not empty,
we get the smallest element out
of it.
And then we do some stuff.
That's it.
And the only thing I should
mention here is,
OK, so let's just see what's
going on here.
And then we'll run it on the
example.
OK, so what we do is we take
out the smallest element out of
the queue at each step.
And then for each step in the
adjacency list,
in other words,
everything for which I have an
edge going from v to u,
we take a look,
and if v is still in our set V
minus A, so things we'(V,E)
taken out are going to be part
of A.
OK, every time we take
something out,
that's going to be a new A that
we construct.
At every step,
we want to find,
what's the cheapest edge
connecting that A to everything
else?
We basically are going to take
whatever that cheapest thing is,
OK, add that edge in,
and now bring that into A and
find the next cheapest one.
And we just keep repeating the
process.
OK, we'll do it on the example.
And what we do,
is every time we bring it in,
I keep track of,
what was the vertex responsible
for bringing me in.
And what I claim is that at the
end, if I look at the set of
these pairs that I'(V,E) made
here, V and pi of V,
that forms the minimum spanning
tree.
So let's just do this.
And, what's that?
We're all set up.
So let's get rid of these guys
here because we are going to
recompute them from scratch.
OK, so you may want to copy the
graph over again in your notes.
I was going to do it,
but it turned out,
this is exactly the board is
going to erase this.
OK, well let me just modify it.
OK, so we start out.
We make everything be infinity.
OK, so that's where I'm going
to keep the key value.
OK, and then what I'm going to
do is find one vertex.
And I'm going to call him S.
And I'm going to do this vertex
here.
We'll call that S.
So basically,
I now make him be zero.
And now, what I do,
is I execute extract min.
So basically,
what I'll do is I'll just shade
him like this,
indicating that he has now
joined the set A.
So, this is going to be A.
And this is element of V minus
A.
OK, so then what we do is we
take a look.
We extract him,
and then for each edge in the
adjacency list,
OK, so for each vertex in the
adjacency lists,
that these guys here,
OK, we're going to look to see
if it's still in Q,
that is, in V minus A.
And if so, and its key value is
less than what the value is at
the edge, there,
we're going to replace it by
the edge value.
So, in this case,
we're going to replace this by
seven.
We're going to replace this by
15, and we're going to replace
this by ten, OK,
because what we're interested
in is, what is the cheapest?
Now, notice that everything in
V minus A, that is,
what's in the priority queue,
everything in there,
OK, now has its cheapest way of
connecting it to the things that
I'(V,E) already removed,
the things that are in A.
OK, and so now I just,
OK, when I actually do that
update, there's actually
something implicit going on in
this priority queue.
And that is that I have to do a
decreased key.
So, there's an implicit
decrease of the key.
So, decreased key is a priority
queue operation that lowers the
value of the key in the priority
queue.
And so, that's implicitly going
on when I look at what data
structure I'm going to use to
implement that priority queue.
OK, so common data structures
for implementing a priority
queue are a min heap.
OK, so I have to make sure that
I'm actually doing this
operation.
I can't just change it and not
affect my heap.
So, there is an implicit
operation going on there.
OK, now I repeat.
I find the cheapest thing,
oh, and I also have to set,
now, a pointer from each of
these guys back to u.
So here, this guy sets a
pointer going this way.
This guy sets a pointer going
this way, and this guy sets a
pointer going this way.
That's my pi thing that's going
to keep track of who caused me
to set my value to what it is.
So now, we go in and we find
the cheapest thing,
again.
And we're going to do it fast,
too.
OK, this is a fast algorithm.
OK, so now we're going to go do
this again.
So now, what's the cheapest
thing to extract?
This guy here,
right?
So, we'll take him out,
OK, and now we update all of
his neighbors.
So this guy gets five.
This guy gets 12.
This guy gets nine.
This guy we don't update.
We don't update him because
he's no longer in the priority
queue.
And all of these guys now,
we make point to where they're
supposed to point to.
And, we're done with that step.
Now we find the cheapest one.
What's the cheapest one now?
The five over here.
Good.
So, we take him out.
OK, we update the neighbors.
Here, yep, that goes to six
now.
And, we have that pointer.
And, this guy we don't do,
because he's not in there.
This guy becomes 14,
and this guy here becomes
eight.
So, we update that guy,
make him be eight.
Did I do this the right way?
Yeah, because pi is a function
of this guy.
So basically,
this thing, then,
disappears.
Yeah, did I have another one
that I missed?
12, yes, good,
it's removed,
OK, because pi is just a
function.
And now I'm OK.
OK, so now what do I do?
OK, so now my set,
A, consists of these three
things, and now I want the
cheapest edge.
I know it's in the minimum
spanning tree.
So let me just greedily pick
it.
OK, so what's the cheapest
thing now?
This guy appear?
Yeah, six.
So we take it.
We go to update these things,
and nothing matters here.
OK, nothing changes because
these guys are already in A.
OK, so now the cheapest one is
eight here.
Good.
So, we take eight out.
OK, we update this.
Nothing to be done.
This: nothing to be done.
This: oh, no,
this one, instead of 14 we can
make this be three.
So, we get rid of that pointer
and make it point that way.
Now three is the cheapest
thing.
So, we take it out,
and of course there's nothing
to be done over there.
And now, last,
I take nine.
And it's done.
And 15: it's done.
And the algorithm terminates.
OK, and as I look at,
now, all the edges that I
picked, those are exactly all
the edges that we had at the
beginning.
OK, let's do an analysis here.
OK, so let's see,
this part here costs me order
V, right?
OK, and this part,
let's see what we are doing
here.
Well, we're going to go through
this loop how many times?
V times.
It's V elements we put into the
queue.
We are not inserting anything.
We're just taking them out.
This goes V times,
OK, and we do a certain number
of extract Mins.
So, we're going to do order V
extract Mins.
And then we go to the adjacency
list, and we have some constant
things.
But we have these implicit
decreased keys for this stuff
here.
That's this thing here.
OK, and so how many implicit
decreased keys do we have?
That's going to be the
expensive thing.
OK, we have,
in this case,
the degree of u of those.
OK, so overall,
how many implicit decreased
keys do we have?
Well, we have V times through.
How big could the degree of u
be?
OK, it could be as big as V,
order V.
So, that's V^2 decreased use.
But we can do a better bound
than that.
How many do we really have?
Yeah, at most order E,
OK, because what am I doing?
I'm summing up the degrees of
all the vertices.
That's how many times I
actually execute that.
So, I have order E,
implicit decreased keys.
So the time overall is order V
times time for whatever the
extract Min is plus E times the
time for decreased key.
So now, let's look at data
structures, and we can evaluate
for different data structures
what this formula gives us.
So, we have different ways of
implementing a data structure.
We have the cost of extract
Min, and of decreased key,
and total.
So, the simplest way of
implementing a data structure is
an unsorted array.
If I have an unsorted array,
how much time does it take me
to extract the minimum element?
If I have an unsorted array?
Right, order V in this case
because it's an array of size V.
And, to do a decreased key,
OK, I can do it in order one.
So, the total is V^2,
good, order V^2 algorithm.
Or, as people suggested,
how about a binary heap?
OK, to do an extract Min in a
binary heap will cost me what?
O of log V.
Decreased key will cost me,
yeah, it turns out you can do
that in order log V because
basically you just have to
shuffle the value,
actually shuffle it up towards
the root, OK?
Or at log V.
And, the total cost therefore
is?
E log V, good.
Which of these is better?
It depends, good.
When is one better,
and when is the other better?
Yeah, if it's a dense graph,
E is close to V^2,
the array is better.
But if it's a sparse graph,
and E is much smaller than V^2,
then the binary heap is better.
So that motivated the invention
of a data structure,
OK, called a Fibonacci Heap.
So, Fibonacci Heap is covered
in Chapter 20 of CLRS.
We're not going to hold you
responsible for the content,
but it's an interesting data
structure because it's an
amortized data structure.
And it turns out that it is
data structure,
you can do extract Min in order
log V amortized time.
And remarkably,
you can do decreased key in
order one amortized.
So, when I plug those in,
what do I get over here?
What's that going to be?
Plug that it here.
It's going to be V times log V
plus E: E plus V log V.
These are amortized,
so what's this?
Trick question.
It's worst-case.
It's not amortized over here.
These are amortized,
but that's the beauty of
amortization.
I can say it's going to be
worst case: E plus V log V over
here, because when I add up the
amortized cost of my operations,
it's an upper bound on the true
costs.
OK, so that's why I say,
one of the beauties of this
amortized analysis,
and in particular,
being able to assign different
costs to different operations is
I can just add them up and I get
my worst-case costs.
So this is already V log V.
There are a couple other
algorithms just before I let you
go.
Kruskal's Algorithm in the book
uses another amortized data
structure called a disjoint set
data structure,
which also runs in E log V,
that is, this time:
runs in this time,
the same as using a binary
heap.
So, I'll refer you to the book.
The best algorithm to date with
this problem is done by our own
David Karger on the faculty here
with one of our former
graduates, Phil Kline,
who is now a professor at
Brown, and Robert Tarjan,
who is sort of like the master
of all data structures who was a
professor at Princeton in 1993.
OK, it's a randomized
algorithm, and it gives you
order V plus E expected time.
OK, so that's the best to date.
It's still open as to whether
there is a deterministic,
there is worst-case bound,
whether there is a worst-case
bound that is linear time.
OK, but there is a randomized
to linear time,
and otherwise,
this is essentially the best
bound without additional
assumptions.
OK, very cool stuff.
Next, we're going to see a lot
of these ideas of greedy and
dynamic programming in practice.